hello everyone another thing to react to
i'm sure there's gonna be a lot of that
in the next two weeks even though it's
not technically e3 e3 is cancelled this
year everybody's still dropping
everything in june so this is the sonic
frontiers world premiere gameplay it's
part of ign first uh basically once a
month sorry rather throughout the month
ign does things that would act like
magazine cover stories where they just
feature one game really heavily for a
month then i guess this is their first
drop it is seven minutes of sonic
gameplay and judging by this first
starting screen
i'm curious
what is this this doesn't look like
sonic at all so
i'm gonna make myself
a bit smaller up here and uh jump in and
making sure it's in crispy crispy 4k
it does already look a little bit off
um all right let's check it out
ign first for the month of june two
thousand mitchell assaults all about
sonic frontiers we've got gameplay we've
got previews and we've got interviews
from the developers who made it all
happen all month long we'll be diving
deep into what you can expect when the
game makes its way to you later down the
road first up we've got the world
premiere gameplay focusing on exploring
oh i remember this trailer i loved the
trailer i thought the trailer looked
awesome at the start of the game be sure
to stick with ign throughout june so you
don't miss anything until then here's
your first look at gameplay from sonic
frontier is this open world
how does it
what
oh the movement looks really strange
ah
this is not good
why does his movement look so off
it looks like he has no impact on the up
the walls looks cool like i'm sure going
up that ramp will look cool but
this is a very interesting setting for
sonic
don't get me wrong there
what
what
oh okay maybe that was just showing
climbing gameplay
i mean this is somebody trying to show
off the world right so they're trying to
like like mitchell probably recorded
this he's probably trying to show off
how some different stuff looks which
makes it look like it's not really
flowing it's also like the
pop in
i always hate criticizing sonic because
sonic fans
just get real mad i'm gonna do it anyway
obviously
but they will come for me every time
[Music]
i mean that looks cool
even though like lighting effects
um
i mean i like that
that's pretty cool this is definitely
very different
it is open walt how do you what do you
how do you get direction
is it just like one sandbox
that makes it seem more like a tech demo
it's the odd styles of clashing with
each other i think that's why the the
lighting was so off
like the collection of the rings does
not suit this environment
[Music]
that's pretty
[Music]
[Music]
i know what that's supposed to do
okay i'm hoping to see some variety some
a little bit more variety in the
environment here
it's definitely like
curious
it's the word i will use it's curious
the choices
are
curious
[Music]
i'm bored um
showing seven minutes of this is it was
odd of sega to approve and like the
spinning the light it's just the clashes
of them
maybe they just really wanted to make
something
pop in
really early stages of development
potentially
i mean this is just a weird way to
showcase this as well it's very
directionless oh that's pretty
i like a flower
this is seven minutes
okay it's almost over
i'm just sort of the same thing
a lot of pop in
lack of direction
no forward thrust which is what you
would think that you would want from
sonic
who apparently gotta go fast
oh
people are gonna be very upset with me
or maybe i'm not alone
i do not think this looks good
unfortunately could be really early um
and i'm not gonna rule it out because it
it's it's it's different right it's
different it's not um
you just gotta run across all the
squares
you just gotta you just gotta get all
the squares
there you go
[Music]
really
this is also just not it's just not
great
i guess it's not gameplay not the
marketing department for sega
[Music]
oh um
yeah
i
remember thinking that this looked great
i'm pretty sure at least i'll have to go
back and watch it i remember thinking oh
interesting
um
really not into this but i still feel
like okay it does look like a tech demo
a lot of pop in
weird collision his movement looks very
strange
um but it is early and and very
directionless gamepl
i'm scared to scroll down to the
comments which i always do
but i'm scared
because if people don't agree with me
i'm gonna get so badly harassed for this
video which i will publish anyway
i will take your harassment it wouldn't
be the first time
the game looks bad i'm sorry
i really hope the comments
aren't like
super positive okay let's take a look
shall we how does the internet feel
about sonic frontiers
oh
ricky bo it looks like a tech demo
that's exactly what i said
um hang on let me move this over a
little bit
go
here
and then here
honestly sonic's movement is pretty
decent i don't know about that the
problem is if he doesn't have enough
momentum it's really cool to get faster
than when you run and depend on boost
and not depend on boost i mean that is
an issue with this video for sure is
that there's a lack of momentum because
nothing was really strung together
looking forward to see what the sonic
team does with the final product it
still looks like a tech demo to current
stage agreed to be fair there's a lot of
a lot that sega is probably not showing
it us at this time just don't rush it i
agree with that also i'm not going to
like say hard no
this is just the first video um could be
more than this i can't wait to see the
enemies allies side quests etc if that's
what they're planning it's crazy how far
fan-made games have become
the game itself is beautiful i don't
know that i agree with that
i don't feel like i thought it looked
beautiful the only grab said it seems
dead definitely agree there's no
wildlife anywhere except for that one
bird the other thing is sonic seems
really slow for some reason he loses
momentum really quickly while taking a
long time build up also agree with that
can't wait for this excited as an
understatement
does seem mostly positive
okay this i think is probably the bigger
problem
this definitely needed a curated
gameplay trailer showcasing features and
mechanics not someone running around
aimlessly i'm excited to get me wrong
but cautious um
agree with that i think that the
showcase was
a lot of the problem
agreed that it felt empty and stiff
popping up sonic runs agree with that
yeah
i'm not gonna write it
off but i think this looks bad
currently in this state
in this video
which is not necessarily indicative of
the final release
hopefully